this is the daily climate show lots to
get through today including
hurricane Ian leaves a path of
Destruction as millions are told to
evacuate their homes in Florida
scientists claim damage to the Nord
stream gas pipeline amounts to an
environmental crime as a fourth leak is
found in the Baltic Sea
I'm the host of cop 27 Egypt
urges countries to put political
differences aside ahead of the climate
Summit in November
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes happening to our world and
interrogate some of the potential
solutions to The Climate crisis now over
2 million people have been told to
evacuate their homes as one of the most
powerful storms ever recorded in U.S
history batters Florida's southwest
coast now President Joe Biden has
declared a major disaster in the state
hurricane Ian has brought gusts of up to
190 miles an hour and Rental rain and
scientists believe climate change is
having an impact with the build up of
heat trapping gases from burning fossil
fuels making storms slower and wetter
well the National Hurricane Center says
this is the likely path of the storm now
the storm surge has now passed through
Florida and hurricane Ian has now been
lowered to a category one tropical storm
um after landing in the state yesterday
but residents are being warned that
there are very strong winds and that
will continue for a while the National
Hurricane Center are now warning
residents of widespread life-threatening
catastrophic flooding now the tropical
storm is now expected to move up through
Georgia South Carolina and North
Carolina well Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis held a news conference and
described the impact of the storm as a
historic
foreign the impacts of this storm are
are historic and the Damage that was
done uh has been historic and this is
just off initial assessments there's
going to be a lot more assessing that
goes on uh in the days ahead but I think
we've never seen a flood event like this
we've never seen storm surge of this
magnitude and it hit an area where
there's a lot of people and a lot of
those low-lying areas and it's going to
end up doing extensive damage to a lot
of people's homes so there's going to be
a lot of work to do today is about
identifying the people that need help
who may still be In Harm's Way but also
beginning the process of rebuilding some
of the things that we need to have
Services restored to have fuel and to
have the things that people need in
terms of communications
well let's hear now from NBC
correspondent Chris poloney he has the
latest from Tampa in Florida
it's it's some of the most remarkable
video I've seen in my career uh covering
hurricanes for about 20 25 years just
absolutely stunning to see how rapidly
the storm surge rushed into these
hardested areas places like Fort Myers
and Naples and uh up towards Sarasota a
little bit just a Devastation from the
water as the Gulf of Mexico rushed in
and when you coupled that with 150 mile
an hour winds uh upwards of 200 250
kilometers per hour just really really
devastating the sun has come up now and
so it is literally shedding light on
what's going on we've seen lots of
reports from sheriffs and city and
county leaders in the hardest hit areas
that said that they had a really
difficult time doing much of anything
overnight as the storm was still raging
and now the tough part is trying to just
find these areas that are damaged
because there are so many trees there's
so many any power lines and debris
blocking roads that it's really slowing
the effort down some places do have the
ability to search by air and so we will
see some aircraft going out to try and
look for damage and look for people who
need help but that is all just getting
underway as we uh as we start to see the
sunrise here this morning
okay moving on and a fourth leak has
been reported on the Nordstrom gas
pipeline scientists claim the damage
amounts to an environmental crime if the
oil pipelines were deliberately damaged
now the damage has caused tons of
methane to spill into the Baltic Sea
likely the biggest burst of potent
greenhouse gases on record now the north
stream pipelines carry natural gas from
Russia all the way down to Germany and
this week two leaks were reported on
nordstream one Pipeline and one leak on
nordstream two now all near the Danish
island of born home and Maritime
authorities have established a safety
zone of five nautical miles around the
island well today damage was reported by
Swedish authorities meaning now there
are at least four leagues well our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins is
in at born home Siobhan still an
investigation ongoing of course
um but interesting there that scientists
saying if this is proved deliberate it's
the equivalent of an environmental crime
yes if it is proved to be a deliberate
act then this would be catastrophic for
the environment we know that a huge
amount of methane is being released into
the environment a Danish authorities
saying potentially the equivalent of a
third of Denmark's annual total of
methane being released and of course it
is an extremely potent greenhouse gas
it's one of those gases which of course
is responsible to The Climate
catastrophes that many people are facing
around the world the changing climate
that we're trying to battle so the fact
that this huge amount has potentially
been pumped into the environment over
just a few days is absolutely
catastrophic and as you say some
scientists saying this could be a war
crime if this was deliberately done and
we are hearing now the chorus of voices
coming out really really now starting to
point to sabotage most people in
agreement in Europe that this looks like
a deliberate act that it wasn't some
sort of accident particularly as we now
know that four of the pipelines have
leaks on them and we spoke to
finland's foreign minister this morning
and he reiterated that message
well I think this is unprecedented we
haven't seen that kind of attack or
sabotage on a critical European energy
infrastructure and therefore we we do
not take this uh very easy it's
something which we were working closely
with our allies in EU and NATO and I've
spoken to the US and of course a lot of
other allies in Europe on this issue and
will continue to do until we we find out
what happened and and who did it and and
why did this take place in in in in the
Baltic Sea
that of course was Denmark's foreign
minister speaking to us earlier today
but really the investigations going on
off this Coast will continue experts
telling me that the gas needs to fully
go before they can get down and really
see the damage to those pipelines but
the reality is even if they can find out
what type of explosives for example
cause the damage if it was deliberately
done it's unlikely that they'll ever be
able to fully confirm who was
responsible
okay Siobhan thank you very much for
that let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news for you now
because AGL energy will shut down
Australia's biggest single carbon
polluting power plant a decade earlier
than planned the coal fired Loy Yang a
power station in Victoria will close in
2035 instead of 2045 and AGL Australia's
biggest electricity generator and Pluto
is accelerating its exit from coal
according to a plan released to the
stock exchange on Thursday today the
company said the early closure could
avoid 200 million tons of carbon dioxide
equivalent emissions
now the host of the next U.N climate
Summits has issued a plea for countries
to set aside tensions and animosity over
the war in Ukraine for the sake of
focusing on the climate crisis so last
year leaders agreed to secure Global Net
Zero by mid-century and keep a maximum
of 1.5 degrees of warming Within Reach
in Egypt will host cop 27 in November
intended as a forum for companies to
fulfill the promises they made at cop 26
Summit in Glasgow last year
and you may notice muted autumnal colors
this year instead of the usual display
of Reds and yellows following this
Summer's drought according to the
National Trust now the conservation
charity said the false Autumn seen in
August where many species shed their
leaves prematurely to conserve water and
energy will put a dampener on the change
of season and it warned that without
action the usual passing of Autumn Leaf
Drop could be fundamentally altered as a
pace of climate change increases
now the green part is annual conference
is due to get underway tomorrow and it
comes as the labor leader sakir starmer
says he wants the UK to become a clean
energy superpower and the green party
says they would introduce a tax package
which would result in polluting
companies and the richest households
contributing more to a fund at a
nationwide insulation and renewable
energy program or Skies Chief political
correspondent John Craig joins me now so
it is isn't it John the season of
conferences what can we expect from the
green party particularly after labors
they're calling for attacks the rich
policy the very rich yes labor this week
unveiled plans for what they call a new
company Great British energy uh to take
over uh electricity generation and that
was uh sirma's big announcement in his
speech the greens are meeting in
Harrogate starting tomorrow and their
co-leaders uh Carl denyer and Adrian
Ramsey are going to unveil this policy
which is certainly more left-wing than
anything the labor party is talking
about at the moment uh they're calling
for an emergency package to Halton
reverse Rising inequality and Tackle
climate change a wealth tax on the
richest one percent and a watertight
windfall tax back dated to January is
what they're calling for
um the green party is saying that uh Liz
trust has set out on a climate wrecking
growth at all costs agenda
they say well the deepen inequality and
poison our environment and
they are calling for an emergency tax
package and which will see both
polluters and the riches pay their fair
share uh the wealth tax on the richest
one percent of households and they're
talking about a dirty profit tax forcing
the biggest polluters to pay uh the
green party of course have just got one
MP in Parliament that's Caroline Lucas
but they are in a power sharing
agreement an arrangement with the
Scottish national party uh in Scotland
uh and so uh they have some influence
there but uh it's likely to that this
conference demand for our wealth tax on
the richest one percent is likely to be
pretty uh well rebuffed by the uh the uh
the government however the greens are in
something of a competition with the
liberal democrats for the support of
people uh looking for what vote for one
of the smaller parties and the greens
are clearly out to outflank the liberal
Democrats on when it comes to taxing the
rich and making polluters pay a dirty
profits tax they're talking about okay
John thank you very much as ever well
that's all from the daily climate show
today thank you very much for watching